nina is feeling that you're socially
isolated it's related to being
physically isolated from other people
but it's not the same thing
one can be lonely in a marriage lonely
in a family they can be lonely in a
crowd so we found it isn't the number of
contacts or the frequency of interaction
with other people it's the quality of
those interactions freshmen who have
gone to college find themselves among
many many other people lots of social
activities they go to mixers and they
look out everyone else is talking with
other people and they're sitting there
all alone in their head and so that
actually can make their feeling of
isolation greater for that moment so
being around other people is not what
makes people less lonely it's feeling
connected to other people that makes
them feel less lonely
traditionally loneliness in depression
loneliness and anxiety were treated as
very similar constructs so much so that
one of the common measures of depression
that's used in epidemiology has as one
of the questions do you feel lonely our
own researcher research of others have
looked at whether loneliness and
depression of the same thing and we find
them to be separate contracts their
separate mental states our longitudinal
research and our experimental research
has shown that loneliness leads to
increased depressive symptomatology so
if no matter how depressed you are today
if you're feeling lonely today you will
be more depressed a year from now above
and beyond what your level of depression
today would predict because of the
loneliness we also find that depression
leads you to withdrawal so a difference
in depression and loneliness this
loneliness makes you want to reach out
and contact other people be a part of
that group be a part of that
relationship depression is associated
with depressed effect but also with
lethargy kind of this withdrawal from
others and indeed with depression we
find over time people do withdrawal from
others and that withdrawal and an
increased stress associated with that
leads them to feel lonelier so you have
this pernicious feedback loop but
lonelier they are the more depressed
they become the more depressed they are
the more they withdraw and the lonelier
they become if you look at those two
effects so the effect of loneliness and
depression is stronger than the effect
of depression on loneliness people can
be depressed for other reasons and
feeling lonely but many people who go in
to seek treatment for depression at the
root of the problem is their feeling of
disconnection and isolation and unless
that's treated the depression or any
attempt to fix that is really just kind
of a transient band-aid it's not getting
at the root problem
the measurements of loneliness is
somewhat not obvious people know that
they feel isolated they feel
disconnected they don't have others on
whom they can rely or talk but it's
mostly they don't have a confidant they
don't have anyone who affirms who they
are that's part of it now if you ask
people do they feel lonely there tends
to be this stigma associated with
loneliness I think our research has
suggested it's an inappropriate stigma
but there's nevertheless the stigma
associated with loneliness
so people under report if you ask them
do you feel lonely the under report but
if you ask them are there others some
whom they can rely to whom they can
relate in whom they can confined that's
when you start to see people admitting
this feeling of isolation there's also
the sense in which they don't have a
collective identity so immediately after
9/11 when we all survived that tragedy
it made being an American salient that's
a social identity but if you notice in
this country journalists were writing
about the harmony the goodwill that
existed in America that was a step up
from what had been felt a week before
9/11 that's part of being connected and
so a lonely individual is also absent
that social identity and it may be in
the form of feeling like you're an
American after a tragedy or might be a
Chicago concert New York Yankees fan
these kinds of identities are part of
how we are connected to other odd other
individuals and other groups and lonely
individuals tend to lack those as well
there are simple secrets to overcoming
or avoiding ominous I like to use the
analog of hunger loneliness has evolved
because it has very adaptive purpose we
are fundamentally social species but we
need some signal when that important
need isn't being met very much like
hunger we need a reasonable level of
blood sugar else we don't tab the
metabolic resources the energy to pursue
foraging and other activities when we
start to have lower blood sugar levels
we become hungry and that's a signal
that we should find food and eat and
refuel if we ignore that hunger signal
if we think that somehow that's
stigmatizing and so we simply persist in
not pursuing any food and ignoring that
signal we can become so depleted of
energy that we're no longer able to seek
that food so it can become chronic and
deadly loneliness is very much like that
man instead of sustaining us with
calories it seemed it sustains us with
connections in evolutionary times we
were not able to fend off large wild
beasts very well as individuals with a
stick nor were we able to take care of
our offspring who have the longest
period of abject dependency of any
species if we were simply solitary
animals we are able to achieve
reproduction survival and our offspring
survive long enough so that they to
reproduce because we acted as a group as
a collective so finding yourself
ostracized or separated from that group
is a threatening dangerous circumstance
recognizing that you also can understand
how the feeling of loneliness the pain
of loneliness the threat that's
associated with loneliness is a signal
very much like hunger but it's there to
queue the need to reconnect to protect
that part of our existence and if we
respond to it as that queue then it can
be very healthy if you don't respond to
that queue then you can fall into the
grips of chronic loneliness and
has but as I suggested very deleterious
mental psychological effects but also
physiological effects